i like to place my toe
like just on the ground then it's all
about you know getting there and then
let's go
when you reach your goals and i guess
when you won the world championships for
the first time you know a lot around
your life it changed you know and the
same for me especially after tokyo and
it's it's
you need to find your place
in that new
world or that new scenario
we're both in a in a situation where you
know
only the best is good enough both for
ourselves and for everybody around and
it's actually a difficult situation to
to be in all the time that's why you
need these into individual
goals that you
set yourself because you need to have
something that drives you forward yeah
exactly you have something that has to
motivate you to do all the right things
so now my new goal is to reach a 2 900
rating and for me it's not so much about
reaching
the goal it's it's about having a goal
because that motivates me to do the
right things
and
frankly the last world championship
it didn't really motivate me that much i
couldn't really i feel forced myself to
do the things that i needed to do to be
at my very best and i was more focused
on
like i want it to be over i want to not
lose this time so that i can do other
things that i like more when it comes to
this new goal i'm much more motivated to
do the right things
to have at least a chance of achieving
that goal because i feel achieving that
would be
special that would be an historic uh
achievement frankly in some other
tournaments like
i know
that
i can do 90
and probably win
but
if i want to achieve my goal now it has
to be 100
every single time and that is motivating
[Music]
i'm actually a bit nervous
we're going to play a game called hand
and brain so i'm going to be the hand
he's going to tell me what piece to move
and i'm going to move that piece
and that's going to be the same over
here i'm obviously his brain
he's obviously the brain big brain
porn
okay
i like it i like it
i don't see a single pawn mode that i
like
porn nice
you saw the threat that's good
oh that was important i didn't see it
okay we're getting a bit short of time
running out of time runner run
so one second running out of time queen
ah we're lost in time i think i have to
take the blame here i do know
do you find it inspiring magnus that
caution has broken that magical limit
and now you're aiming for your own
magical limits yeah for sure because he
didn't need to break the the world
record needed to completely shatter it
and that's what i'll have to do as well
the difference between the rating i have
now and and the goal is it's not that
big it's just that the others are so
like far behind that to actually gain
rating on what what i what i had what so
your problem is actually that you know
you need others to be able to be right
exactly how you want to be ranked so
that's a problem when you were ranked at
2 800 and yeah or something that that's
that's the world record right yeah
that's that's the world record yeah but
those were those were like different
days that was back in 2014 and back then
i knew a lot less about chess than i do
today but i just had so much
willpower
every single time i sat down like i
expected to win every time that i play
and i would work tirelessly for
five six hours every time to get there
so that's what i'm trying to get back to
[Music]
you